[音楽]
こんにちは
君は何がやりたいわけ
何もできないです
だったらなんでもやってみるんだよ
はいわかりました
そんなた場合のもないからから始まった仕事
くることすべてを魅力的に帰ると言う
変わった会社に私は入れていただきました
次々と繰り出される難問珍問に答えながらも
一向に相手にされない毎日でした
一体どうして私はここに入れていただいているんだろうと思いながらも
途方に暮れる時間を過ごしていましたが
古いお城の天守閣が
時々もあるなんてどうですか
何の前触れもなく時々
と私が答えるとボスが
君方読まない方がいいよ君の持っている感覚は
何かに影響されるとどんどん薄くなると思うから
いいのよ
家でちょっとバカな方が気づくことがたくさんあるだけよ
そんなん
褒められているのか気なされているのか分からない
役所でもそのものすごく説得力のある言葉が
いつも私に力をくれましたそんなボスは
その昔
若い頃ですね40回も面接を受けたけれども1個に雇ってもらえず
そしてトート今の仕事にたどり着いたとこぼしていました
路頭に迷った挙句
テキ屋の親分とポーカーをしてあって場所をもらえて
それでたらこの販売をさせてもらうようになったと
m のなものですから全然売れないし
どんどん腐るのでそこで考えたのが
たらこスパゲティーだったそうです
作り方をプリントして貴女の奥さんに二貼りだしたらどんどん売れるようになったんだ
よね
あれ考えたの僕だから
たらこスパゲティの発症が
こんなところにあったなんて
実はそのボスは皆さんもご存知なたくさんのブランド名や商品名の生みの親でもあるん
です
私はそんなボスの下で毎日楽しんでたくさんの仕事をしました
何でもやりました取材もしました
文章を書きました
使いパシリ編集の手伝い設営撤収作業
ビラ配り
カラオケ絶対
スタンドインのモデルも
そんなある日ボスから
毎日新聞の機会しかつ人で衣装制作の仕事をしてみなさいと命じられました
私は
毎日新聞だったら新聞紙を使って服を作ってもいいですかと申し出け
摩訶不思議な
新聞紙のドレスを纏った11人の補正的な女の子たちを作り上げました
れ上なり得る
なんちゃってフランス語で
それらしいタイトルを付けました
そんなことが高じて
衣装製作が何前に
その後コラソンというスターリストの会社を立ち上げて今に至るというわけです
+豚とは
スペイン語で
心=ハートという意味です
音馬といえばそのボスと出会う前
私は憧れのファッションブランドのデザイナー
こぐれひでこさんのアトリエで営業の仕事をさせてもらっていました
軽やかで広域で元気の出るとっ子役みたいだったその服に合わせて髪をベリーショート
のカリアゲにして
毎日
楽しくふわふわと仕事をしていたら広告や
雑誌のモデルを頼まれるようになり最後には歌手として歌を歌ってみないかということ
にまで
その時声をかけてくれた眺望人こそがひで子さんの友人でもあった
そんなおかしなモス1読んで面白し
スーパーエディターの今は亡き秋山みちおさんだったのです
私は完璧だと思うものよりもどこか
ひしゃげていたりはぐれ者ように孤独感を醸し出しているようなそんなものにとても
魅力を感じてしまうんですそんなものがひとたび輝いて見えたりしたら
完璧な美しいものよりも何十倍も魅力を放つに違いない
そんなことを考えながらなぁ
スタイリストの仕事をしていると
あんなものがあったらいいのにな
こんなものがあったらいいのになと思うことがよくありました
そのなかの1つで
ジュエリーがありました
ある日
友人が問われる jd サッカーの方を紹介してくださって自分のデザインするじゅ
えりお
作ってみることにしました2つ3つとうち二が増えて
それを仕事で持ち歩くと女優さんやモデルさんから
それを変えたいとおっしゃっていただくことが増え
そうこうしているうちにあるドラマで女優さんが付けてくださることになりました
ブランド名はと聞かれてあっじゃあ考えなくちゃってことになったんです
ジュエリーというと白鳥高くてゴージャスというイメージがありますが
私が欲しいのはそうではない密やかだけど
存在感があって
でも妙に印象的で
身につける人に寄り添い
気持ちを少しだけ上げてくれる
ナチュラルメイクのような j リー
何だろうそれは密かなもの
かつ金物
可視化な10位
そんなネーミングを探すためにかすかという言葉はないか
辞書を引いてみました
そしたらあったんですスペイン語の意味は
荒屋でした
あぱら屋
口当てた家
そう思った途端に
子供の頃
友達と
放置されている空き家に基地を作って
たからものの隠し場所にしていたときのことが思い出されたんです
我楽多屋
角が丸くなって落ちていた
きれいな青いガラス瓶の欠片や
不思議な形の石や
感動した風景
朝露にぬれて
キラキラと輝くクモの巣とか
流れ星の残像とか
あの鏡台の引き出しの奥に
忘れられていた
古びた指文
壊れたうで退け使い込まれて傷ついてはいるけれど
その傷は200とまるで独特なカットを施したようにキラキラと輝くその傷一つひとつ
に想いや命があるかのように私が魅力的だと思うのは
こういうことだったんだとやっと気付いたんです
人は
たくさんの経験をして
身も心も傷を位
はたまた手話も寄ってきてっ
でもその全てを受け入れ
重ねた年相応に
自分のものにして
チャーミングな魅力に変えていくのはその人自身の力です
心の傷も顔の島6
様々な輝きに変えたい
静かに控えめに
しかし
印象的に輝く
独特な輝きで
そんな思いを持って誕生したジュエリーですがドラマで使われて問い合わせが殺到し
それに背中を押される形でホームページを立ち上げて
中心販売を始めました
私は基本的に時代に左右されないものが好きです
ありきたりなネックレスチェーンに少しカットを施して
光の反射を多くしたり
職人さんにモチーフの上からタッチを加えてもらって
そこが地下ちらキラキラと輝くように工夫したりしていることで映像では思いのほか目
を引くようです
その
不思議な輝きで印象的な存在感を残すのかもしれません
突然のアクシデントに見舞われた時
今まで味わったことのないような思え金 gree
何かに気づかせてもらう事って
ありませんか
私も
たくさんの人と出会い
別れ
恋愛の山谷掛プチ
裏切り
離婚結構
出産子育て気
病気
最近でも大きな ko しました
でもそんなことを経験するたびに
何かを得てきたと実感しています失敗だってそうです
間違ってしまったことって
とても愛しくてかわいいものなので
お茶目だなって思うんです
だからその失敗をムダにせずにデザインに変えてしまう
その結果が想像はるかに超えた
素敵なものになり
思いもよらない作品に生まれてしまうことだってあると思うんです
失敗はどれだけしてきた彼が財産ですよね
それを無駄にすることなく大切で
豊かな窯焼きに支えられたら
そんな思いを持って誕生した
ジェリーのそのモチーフ一つ一つに私は名前を付けることにしました
何かに例えてみたほうがイメージが湧くのではないかと思ったからです
風にのって浮遊する
植物の胞子のように見える華奢なクロスには発火
小学校の拒否しに旧校舎イバイの花としてあった
あの楕円形な形思わせるモチーフには
ヒヤシンス中
笑った顔のモチーフに
nikko
動物でも友達でも
名前で呼んだ途端
浸し味がなくものですよね
その昔お菓子のボスは
すべての人ものことぐう館に
愛情方向け
慈しみながら面白おかしく
うに出す仕事をしていました
私はそれを傍らで見ていて
いつしかそんなことが身についてしまったのだと思います
どんなことでもやればいいよやってみるんだよ
やりたいなができないことはないんだよ
ホラー
できたじゃない
そんな無責任のようでいて
後ろでしっかり受け止めてくれる言葉は
今でも時々天から降りて来てっ
私を励ましてくれます
そんな想いを
まとうように身につける
お守りのように
ジェリーって
ある集
そんな
i シンカーを添えてくれる宝物だと思うんですよね
大切な宝物は
肌身離さず身につけていったいっ
でも
少し気分が変わって
宝石箱の中に
置き去りにすることがあったとしても
暗がりの中でそっと静かに輝いて
宝物としての誇りは決して失わないでほしい
そんな思いを込めて
私はこれからもジュエリーを皆さんにお届けしていきたいと思っています
そして
何かに気づかせてくださる
沢山の
ひとものことに感謝の気持ちを持って
私はこれからもものづくり
衣装作り
そしてスターリングを
続けていこうと思います
ありがとうございます
[拍手]